[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
harcèlement scolaire et cyber
harcèlement
injures menaces brimades messages
injurieux à répétition le harcèlement
scolaire et le cyberharcèlement touche 6
à 10 % des élèves chaque année
ils brident la liberté individuelle
porte atteinte à l'égalité en droits et
fracasse l'idéal de fraternité
les réseaux sociaux par leur puissance
leur anonymat et leur viralité en
démultiplie les effets
se crée alors un continuum de violence
entre l'école et la sphère familiale
privée
face à ce phénomène
65% des enseignants s'estiment mal armé
du fait d'un manque de formation de
difficultés à détecter les cas de
harcèlement ou d'une absence de soutien
de leur hiérarchie
fort de ce constat le sénat a installé
en mai 2021 une mission d'information
sur le harcèlement scolaire et le cyber
harcèlement présidée par sabine van
heghe dont colette mélot à la
rapporteure
le rapport établi après plusieurs mois
de travail souligne des lacunes dans les
dispositifs actuels de lutte contre le
harcèlement
ainsi la panoplie actuelle d'outils
existants contre le harcèlement scolaire
reste mal connue des élèves et de leurs
parents
en outre l'arsenal juridique reste
limitée face aux cyber harcèlement dont
un quart des collégiens seraient
victimes
l'activité sur ses réseaux sociaux dont
le siège social ne se trouve pas en
france se fait sur des messageries
protégés par le secret des
correspondances
mieux prévenir détecter et traiter
telles sont les recommandations de la
mission d'information sur le harcèlement
scolaire et les cyber harcèlement
elle suggère notamment de former les
enseignants au repérage des situations
de harcèlement et de faire remonter
systématiquement au niveau de l'académie
les faits de harcèlement
elle encourage aussi la généralisation
des partenariats entre l'éducation
nationale la police gendarmerie et la
justice pour que les faits de
harcèlement soit traiter
systématiquement et sans délai
toutefois le rapport souligne qu'une
action efficace ne peut se concevoir que
dans un cadre européen en particulier
pour contrôler que les réseaux sociaux
respectent leur objectif de suppression
des contenus litigieux
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]